this is quite possibly the most
controversial graph in the history of
science and last month it got one hell
of an update
thanks to curiosity stream and nebula
for sponsoring this video this is the
so-called hockey stick a graph of the
past 1000 years of the earth's average
surface temperature created in 1999 by
scientists raymond bradley malcolm
hughes and michael mann now depending on
who you are you may be very familiar
with this figure as either putting
recent global warming in shocking
context or evidence of one of the most
diabolical scams in the history of
science but before getting to that let's
quickly talk about how it was made
obviously people weren't taking accurate
global average temperature readings back
in 1000 ad so to work out what the
temperature was back then the authors
used what's known as proxy measurements
imagine that you want to know how many
monkeys have lived in a particular
forest for the past century you know
that there are 1 000 monkeys this year
there were 980 last year and 1020 the
year before that but you don't know this
number any further into the past you do
however know how many mango seeds have
been found on the floor for the past 100
years scientists are weird and like
measuring things don't question it the
number of mango seeds on the floor will
correlate with the number of monkeys the
more monkeys there are the more mangoes
they eat and the more seeds they drop on
the forest floor so given the last three
years of data knowing both the number of
monkeys and the number of mango seeds
performing some statistical analysis you
can estimate the number of monkeys
present over the past 100 years we say
that the mango seeds act as a proxy
measurement for the number of monkeys
obviously it's not a perfect proxy
because the number of mango seeds found
on the forest floor could be affected by
other factors like the weather if it's
windy then mangoes will be blown off of
the trees and onto the forest floor or
disease or other animals that eat
mangoes so to improve our estimate of
the number of monkeys in the forest we
could incorporate multiple proxies into
our calculation so for example we could
look at the number of mango seeds found
on the forest floor every year but also
if there's a town nearby that gets
raided by the monkeys the number of
vegetables that are stolen from that
town's gardens every year the 1999
hockey stick effectively did this with
temperature in the northern hemisphere
estimating it using 12 proxy
measurements spread across the globe
those proxies were mostly tree ring data
so if you drill into the center of a
tree and extract a core you can see how
long the tree has been alive by counting
the alternating bands of growth that
correspond to the different seasons
but because trees grow more in warmer
years while the number of bands will
tell you how long the tree has been
alive the thickness of each year's band
will tell you how warm that year was as
in the monkey example however doing this
isn't a perfect estimate especially if
you're trying to estimate a global
temperature from just a handful of
proxies and the authors were very clear
in 1999 about this you can see how large
the uncertainty in the estimate is up
until about 400 years ago when
additional proxy data became available
that just tighten things up the
conclusion of this graph is pretty
shocking the global average temperature
was quite consistent up until the
industrial revolution at which point
humans started emitting lots of
greenhouse gases into the atmosphere and
the temperature
shot up so the graph looks like a hockey
stick it's got this long straight ish
handle and then there's a short sharp
upturn at the end which is like the
blade of the hockey stick and it was
interpreted as being pretty conclusive
evidence that humans were impacting the
global climate and causing it to warm
and the graph became associated in
particular with the ipcc's third
assessment report but was that
conclusion actually correct a flurry of
papers follow the 1999 hockey stick
claiming that the scientists and in
particular michael mann became kind of
the center of attention had bungled the
statistics a particular claim was that
based on a different analysis of the
same data the handle of the hockey stick
should have been a lot curvier in
particular there was the so-called
medieval warm period when temperatures
were higher than at present a few
centuries ago and then in the early
modern period a few centuries after that
there was a cooler time so observed 20th
century warming was actually just kind
of a readjustment out of that cooler
period and thus the humans weren't
warming the climate anywhere near as
much as man et al claimed this escalated
into a whole thing called climate gate
which involved a hack of emails and
multiple legal cases and lots of threats
being made against climate scientists
and mandy tells it all in his book the
hockey stick and the climate wars which
i may end up doing a video just about
this one day let me know in the comments
if you would like a video just about
climategate but the short version is
that in the past 20 years dozens of
independent studies have come out that
have pretty much verified the shape of
the hockey stick pretty flat with this
uptick at the end it turns out that the
medieval warm period just wasn't as warm
as some authors thought and that it was
actually more of a regional phenomenon
rather than a global warming as more
proxy data sets have become available
from tree rings but also things like
cave deposits and lake sediments and
oxygen isotope analysis and corals and
proxy data sets are kind of wild we've
become more confident in the hockey
stick and we shrunk the uncertainties
basically the conclusion of the original
man bradley and hughes paper has been
validated however last month a new paper
came out that did things a little
differently and made a big leap in how
we can reconstruct past temperatures
osmond et al published in nature created
what we call a re-analysis
normally when we talk about re-analyses
it's in the context of modern climate
data what they are is this combination
of actual observations and statistical
modeling to fill in the gaps where we
don't have weather stations or we don't
have accurate satellite data or balloon
data so it gives us this global
continuous data set that's really
valuable when you're doing research what
this paper did was construct the first
global reanalysis of past surface
temperature it basically plotted out
where hundreds of proxy measurements
were taken using a 200 year resolution
so we have an indirect measurement of
surface temperature at these locations
averaged over 200 years then the
researchers for the first time used
bayesian modeling techniques to fill in
the gaps between the proxies so they
estimated the spatial distribution of
surface temperature they recreated the
map of average surface temperature if
you like in 200-year chunks informed by
how we see temperatures change between
these proxy locations today this took
you may not be surprised to hear a lot
of work it took the scientists seven
years to produce this statistical model
drawing on disciplines like hydrology
and geochemistry and biology and
lots of specialist knowledge into this
one
frankly remarkable statistical model the
result is pretty amazing the hockey
stick now goes back 24 000 years we can
really clearly see the earth coming out
of the last ice age and how since then
for the past 5000 years or more the
earth's global temperature has been very
consistent the handle of the hockey
stick is longer than before and
straighter than before that puts modern
warming in even sharper context because
previous studies that had basically just
taken averages of the proxy measurements
had found that the earth had been
cooling over the past 10 000 years or so
and thus
at some point in the relatively recent
past the earth had actually been as warm
as today if not a little warmer whereas
this far more sophisticated analysis
found the opposite they found that the
earth had been very slightly warming and
thus the modern human-induced climate
change caused by the emission of
greenhouse gases was pushing the earth's
climate to a place that it hadn't been
for
a very long time at least since before
the last ice age and yes that's another
aspect of this paper the authors
disentangled the likely causes of the
observed cooling and warming over the 24
000 year time period considered about
three and a half percent of the warming
is due to changes in the earth's orbit
and ocean circulations with the rest
being due to changes in greenhouse gases
and surface reflectivity as when the ice
age ended the earth became less
reflective note that that's not just
human emissions of greenhouse gases it
actually refers to any changes in the
concentration of greenhouse gases in the
atmosphere human on short time scales
and natural on much longer time scales
this is an amazing paper it puts the
modern warming that we've seen over the
past couple of hundred years into even
starker contrast because it shows that
it's just unprecedented in the recent
record and further that by emitting more
and more greenhouse gases into the
atmosphere and pushing the global
average temperature up and up
every year we are pushing the world's
climate further and further from
anything that we as modern humans have
ever experienced
before the science has come a long way
since the original hockey stick paper
and we understand the mechanism by which
this warming is taking place and its
historical context better than ever
before we understand it really very well
now
so can we please do something about this
changes in global and regional climate
have re-written human history and quite
possibly led to homo sapiens rather than
neanderthals being the dominant species
on this planet
this is covered in fascinating detail in
how climate made history one of the
thousands of documentaries available on
curiosity stream this video is sponsored
curiosity stream is the number one
source of professional productions on
topics from climate to politics history
to
samurai swords
think netflix but smart instead of
covering you with crisps and regret
watching it actually makes you better
informed about the world if however
you'd prefer something a bit more indie
something with that bit more of a
homespun personal touch then look no
further than nebula the streamy award
nominated service owned and operated by
a bunch of youtubers like me who wanted
independence from well
youtube we don't like ads so nebula has
none of them in the videos or on its
pages instead it's a subscription-based
service with your money funding
exclusive original content like
technorama about how movies portray
technology as well as directly
supporting creators on the platform like
me also we are finally now available on
your tv via our roku app but why have i
told you about these two services
because you can get both of them in a
bundle signing up at curiositystream.com
simon clark you can get access to
curiositystream and nebula and get a 26
discount on both just 14.79 a year for
the best documentaries on the internet
and finance exciting new educational
content that's curiositystream.com
simon clark to improve your viewing
experience online and support this
channel
thank you very much for watching this
video this was an installment in my
series going through recent papers and
atmospheric science and kind of
translating them for a popular audience
and i love making these videos so i
really hope that you liked it if you did
please do pop it a like if you do want
to check out some previous episodes in
this series then here are some over here
you can also check out curiositystream
down here and that just leaves me to say
thank you very much for watching and
i'll see you in the next one